[Musique]
au bout d'un sentier au beau milieu de
la forêt se dresse une grande maison à
l'aspect plutôt atypique brick rouge
balcon vert il s'agit de la datcha ou
maison secondaire du célèbre écrivain
russe
Ivan tourgagnès
en 1875 ce dernier décide de s'installer
à Bougival dans le domaine des frênes
pour suivre ses deux amis louis Viardot
et sa femme Pauline Viardot grande
cantatrice il a écrit en russe en
français
il a écrit son livre peut-être le plus
connu
peut-être les mémoires d'un chasseur qui
se compose de plusieurs nouvelles qui se
passent en Russie c'est extrêmement
poétique parce qu'il décrit
merveilleusement bien les paysages
étaient beaucoup plus dans le compromis
entre la culture européenne et la
culture russe c'est pour ça qu'on a dit
que c'était le plus européen des grands
écrivains russes grâce à l'association
des Amis d'yvantours gagnaires de
Pauline Viardot et de Maria malibon la
Dacia est sauvée de justesse de la
démolition en 1979 aujourd'hui elle est
sur la route historique des maisons
d'écrivains et sera bientôt labelliser
maison des illustres par le ministère de
la Culture
dans cette demeure reconstituée à
l'identique le visiteur peut retrouver
le cabinet de travail de l'écrivain
sachant ou encore son piano inscrit au
Monument Historique ouverte jusqu'au 29
octobre les premiers et 3e samedi de
chaque mois c'est l'occasion de
découvrir la vie du romancier alors ils
vont au Guenièvre au fur et à mesure de
ses déplacements à travers l'Europe a pu
connaître énormément de personnes que ce
soit dans les domaines de la littérature
la musique la peinture et eau évidemment
il a rencontré des grands noms comme
George Sand ou Guy de Maupassant selon
les époques
George Sand était principalement une
amie de louis Viardot et c'est elle qui
a beaucoup œuvré pour que pour le
mariage entre Pauline et louis Viardot
et là où étaient les Viardot pour gagner
ce n'était pas très loin en contrebas de
la datcha série-je la villa viardo
rénovée depuis 2019 elle sera inaugurée
lors des Journées Européennes du imoine
en septembre le site sera transformé en
centre européen de la musique mais aussi
en un centre de documentation sur
Pauline Viardot et Yvan Tourgueniev les
deux demeures seront ainsi enfin réunis